let's do a worked example where we
calculate the standard potential at 25
degrees celsius for this reaction
in this redox reaction silver cations
are reduced to form solid silver and
solid chromium is oxidized to form the
cr3 plus ion the first step is to write
down the half reactions that make up the
overall redox reaction so we said that
silver cations are reduced therefore
need to gain an electron to turn into
solid silver and solid chromium to turn
into chromium three plus ions must lose
three electrons
next we need to find the standard
voltages for our two half reactions and
to do that we could consult a standard
reduction potential table and here's our
table that shows standard reduction
potentials for some reduction half
reactions at 25 degrees celsius the
standard reduction potentials or
standard reduction voltages for these
half reactions are all compared to
the reduction of h plus ions so two h
plus plus two electrons forming hydrogen
gas has a standard reduction potential
of exactly zero volts for our particular
redox reaction we need to know the
reduction potential for the reduction of
silver cations to form solid silver the
standard reduction potential for this
half reaction is equal to positive 0.80
volts
the other half reaction that we need to
know about involves the oxidation of
solid chromium to chromium 3 plus
cations but since this is a standard
reduction potential table the half
reaction is written as a reduction half
reaction the standard reduction
potential for this half reaction is
negative 0.74 volts
but since we need this half reaction
written as an oxidation half reaction if
we were to reverse this half reaction
how it's written we would need to change
the sign of the voltage
so the standard oxidation potential
would be positive 0.74 volts
so i've gone ahead and written in the
voltages for our half reactions the
standard reduction potential for our
half reaction was positive 0.80 volts
and the standard oxidation potential for
our half reaction is positive 0.74 volts
our next step is to make the number of
electrons equal for our two half
reactions and add them together for our
oxidation half reaction we're losing
three electrons but for our reduction
half reaction we're only gaining one
electron therefore we need to multiply
everything through in our reduction half
reaction
by three that gives us three ag plus
plus three electrons goes to three a g
notice that even though we multiplied
everything through in our reduction half
reaction by a factor of three we did not
multiply the standard reduction
potential by a factor of three and
that's because voltage is an intensive
property and doesn't depend on the
amount of substance so it doesn't matter
if we're talking about the reduction of
one mole of silver cations or three
moles of silver cations the standard
reduction potential is the same for both
half reactions
and when we add our two half reactions
together so here are all of the
reactants and then over here would be
all of the products
the three electrons would cancel out on
both sides and give us 3ag plus plus
solid chromium goes to 3ag plus cr3 plus
which gives us back our original redox
reaction
and since we were able to add our two
half reactions together and get our
overall redox reaction to find the
standard voltage for this reaction we
should be able to add together the
voltages for the two half reactions
so positive 0.8 plus 0.74
is equal to positive
1.54 volts
so the standard potential for this redox
reaction at 25 degrees celsius is equal
to positive 1.54 volts
there's another way to calculate the
standard potential for this redox
reaction and this way only uses standard
reduction potentials
so to calculate the standard potential
for the redox reaction we take the
standard reduction potential for the
reduction process and from that we
subtract the standard reduction
potential for the oxidation process
so for our reduction half reaction the
standard reduction potential is equal to
positive 0.80 volts so we'd plug that
into our equation for the reduction
process
and for our oxidation half reaction the
standard reduction potential if you
remember from the standard reduction
potential table
is equal to negative 0.74 volts so that
would get plugged into our equation for
the oxidation process
and when we plug in our voltages we get
the same answer that we got before so
the standard potential for our reaction
is equal to positive
1.54 volts at 25 degrees celsius